hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und heute gibt es ein etwas anderes
video ich möchte euch einmal hinter die
kulissen führen wie denn so ein
youtube-video bei mir entstehen was
alles dazugehört und wie viel arbeit da
drinsteckt ich wollte bei arbeit
eigentlich so machen aber das ist ja
ihr seht auf meinem kanal immer das
fertige produkt was manchmal mehr und
manchmal weniger aufwand war so einen
adventskalender den ich auspacke da
gehört natürlich nicht so viel
vorbereitung oder nachbereitung dazu
aber wenn ich jetzt zb ein cocktail
videodreh wie jetzt für adobe mit harry
potter als thema dann gehört da auf
jeden fall eine menge
vorbereitungsarbeit in der mitte und
nachbereitung dazu die vorbereitung ist
glaube ich ganz klar ich muss mir erst
mal überlegen was für ein thema ich
überhaupt mache und wie ich das umsetzen
möchte meine ideen kommen eigentlich mal
relativ spontan ich mache mir manchmal
natürlich auch gedanken darüber was ich
so ein paar wochen mal machen möchte
worauf ich lust haben welche formate ist
denn so gibt aber in diesem fall war es
dann auch wieder so dass sich dieses
kopf ihr buch gefunden habe und mir
dachte wow
special effects kann man super mit harry
potter verbinden zauberei was gibt's
denn besseres für special effects und
cocktails ich bin die cocktail queen
also hat das super gepasst und ich
dachte mir wir machen cocktails aus
diesem cocktail buch und fühlen ein
bisschen ist national effects rein und
wenn es wie in diesem fall eine
kooperation ist dann muss man natürlich
auch neben dem skript und dem thema
schauen wie bringt man die informationen
von kunden an den zuschauer im fein mit
adobe ist natürlich ganz einfach
seitlich youtube-videos machte benutze
ich die creative cloud und deswegen ihr
habt es ist ein heimspiel für mich mit
der vorbereitung sind wir dann
eigentlich durch wir haben dann noch
natürlich markiert welche komplett wir
denn machen wollen haben die zutaten
eingekauft und dann geht's eigentlich
auch schon an den dreh fans natürlich
super g eine maskenbildnerin zu haben
aber beim make-up mache ich natürlich
selbst an halloween hatte ich schon so
ein hexen make up was uns im dunkel ist
was aber nicht so für harry potter fans
jetzt überlege ich wie wir dass ich eine
barfrau in der welt von harry potter
schweden augen von sie natürlich schon
gemacht da ist zu dunkel angezogen bin
wäre es am besten das ist so ein
bellatrix lestrange make-up wäre auch
nicht so düster aber schon so in die
richtung kaufen hexen eigentlich auch
ihr make-up in der winkelgasse oder kann
man sich mega pinks herbern kann sich
hexen make-up zaubern dann muss man sich
überlegen wie guckt man dann in die
kamera man ist ja meistens frontal und
dann muss es frontal auf gut aussehen
und dann kriege ich es ok
dahin ja das wäre gut gewesen
so make-up brauche mir ungefähr eine
stunde ich sage euch gleich wie lange
ich hier für gebraucht habe und zwar
springen jetzt an das ergebnis mit der
adobe schnitt magie und
superklasse thalia 45 minuten habe ich
jetzt dafür gebraucht bevor ich mein
make up gemacht habe habe ich natürlich
schon die küche dekoriert und timo hat
mir dieses mal geholfen beim drehen und
beim licht aufbauen und wieso machen wir
einfach noch eine zweite lange von da
hier noch einmal kommen lassen die war
ja so oben kommt damit nicht alle kraft
alle die in diesem bereich arbeiten
wissen wie wichtig eigentlich das licht
ist und es macht so viel mit dem bild
aus und es ist natürlich toll wenn man
lang mit verschiedenen farben hat und da
so ein bisschen effekt reinbauen kann
ohne dass man viel nachbereiten muss
kann ich noch ein bisschen weiter von
vorne kommen lassen welche andere
wanderer von vorne ganz einmalig dass
hier zwischen runter können sie einmal
wisst ihr nachrichten einzige der lampen
kriege heute sogar noch mehrere
global der rubel muss einmal die vorne
hin die lampe muss einmal komplett hier
also seite
naja das war
[Musik]
meine liebe nahmen sie kurs
das problem ist diese der küchen
abzugshaube gibt einfach alles licht weg
jetzt haben wir das halleluja könnte die
mir ganz so mutig aber dann hast du
zunächst nicht im auge der gesicht
dynatrace des handlungsbedarfs geleistet
diese hinten dürfen ich jetzt auch gar
nicht irgendwie natürlich total
wichtig ja schon gibt die schöne kannte
wir haben doch keine mittel des vierten
[Musik]
teils ich muss noch einmal umbauen
dieses ding funktioniert aber nicht so
geführt haben also dann von oben schön
wie so ein lichtkegel gemacht aber
den finger am abzug glaube
krimineller kannst du einmal bitte noch
die hier reinstellen ich glaube dann
sind wir wirklich ready steady
sieht aus wie die von michael
pilz
er hätte immer noch bis hin ja komplett
klare wieder schön irgendwann muss noch
einmal drehen so cool aus wie man mit
ihnen noch mehr 14 andreas bisher rein
also nicht so ein bisschen ein paar
farbelemente als nötig
dass
wir
arbeiten heute mit zwei verschiedenen
lichtfarben einmal einen weißen licht
5500 calvin hatte
und natürlich einem wärmeren da sind wir
bei 3800 calvin
klar dann seht ihr noch eine lampe die
ist ganz schön hell und beleuchtet mich
von pinken damit ich vor der kamera dann
so eine schöne kante um mich herum habe
weil sonst die das ein bisschen flach
aus und mit dem licht hinten habe ich
wie so ein normen brandung das ist ein
bisschen hervorsteche dass es ein
bisschen raus kommt tatsächlich will man
noch so ne lampe da hinten macht
leuchten so gläser zum beispiel oder
somit teil das leuchtet dann nochmals in
mehr und hat alles noch mal ein bisschen
so gern gesehen effekt nun diesen
christus würde timo sagen warum haben
wir denn warmes licht und kaltes licht
weil wir von hier war lichtquellen haben
also dieser nicht stein und die kerze
und so sieht es dann im bild aus als ob
das licht von diesen lichtquellen kommt
in echt sind diese lichtquellen viel zu
schwach deswegen würde das niemals mein
gesicht beleuchten und das fängt man
dann halt mit sondern kann vor der
kamera sieht dann aus als ob voll
angerechnet werden ich war komplett
überrascht davon wie cool das hat mal
wieder aus also es ist ja eigentlich nur
unsere küche aber es ist durch die
lichter und durch die special effects so
schön geworden dass man richtig das
gefühl hat man ist so irgendwie in
seiner hexenküche
hier haben wir so eine kleine magische
kerze und ein drachen das eigentlich
kein game of thrones ist aber gut drauf
hast du auch mal hinten haben wir eine
lichtsäule die haben wir grünen
beleuchtet um schlimmeres zu
repräsentieren ich weiß auch nicht warum
wir das gemacht haben ansonsten so ein
kleiner alraune und eine kerze die aber
nicht echt ist das ist eine richtig
schöne film fünf kerze die am alkohol
der sich aus als in der pause für den
liebestrunken trocken ab sind das ist
auch so dass einfach irgendwelche
flaschen ist alles aus wieso das habe
ich auch snabes büro geklaut und dann
kann es nach vier stunden auch schon
losgehen die kamera ist ready der ton
läuft die maske hat gute arbeit
geleistet anni ist ready 4 einsatz timo
steht da und freut sich und alle sind
super gut gelaunt wie immer nah war
und god den logos effekt hat sich timo
überlegt und zwar lag er unter mir mit
einer lampe und sobald ich losgesagt
habe hat er die lampe an gemacht und um
mich herum kam halt dieses blaue licht
& co
wie hast du diese leuchtkugel
darangemacht prinzip ist eigentlich ganz
einfach weil sie den zauberstab gehalten
und dem moment wo du los sagt habe ich
die lampe haben gemacht wird zu bisschen
realistischer
und naja ok jetzt ganz gut und
eigentlich hätte man auch wenn du quasi
den so hoch hebt den zauberstab hätte
man eigentlich auch mal das licht somit
bewegen müssen ja das ist noch ein
bisschen sich die schattenhalb perfekt
verändern wie hast du die leuchtkugel an
den zauberstab gemacht dass ich das dann
auch somit bewegt weil ich bewegt hat
ein ganz bisschen den zauberstab sollten
ab sechs gemacht da packt man dann
klavier über den clip ein herdentier wie
man sieht kommt reingelaufen
können einmal kurz alles die effekte
deaktivieren und dann im ersten schritt
wird man halt machen muss
der trecker in den clip an gewählt hast
kannst du immer eine ente die kamera
bewegungen verfolgen oder bewegung
stabilisieren über bewegung verfolgen
kannst du machen und bekommst du hier so
ein treffpunkt und den ziehst du dann
eben runter zu deinem gewünschten
objekte sitzt der zauberstab
kannst du hier den bereich noch
vergrössern indem er ja suchen soll das
heißt wenn wir das noch schlauer gemacht
hätten hätten wir irgendeinen weiß oder
irgendwas neonfarben ist er vorne dran
gemalt das ist so raus stich vornehmlich
glaube dass es nicht passiert weil es
jetzt hier so dunkel ist und so schlecht
ausgeleuchtet die am anfang wird also
düster gemacht haben hatte er beim
trekking oder jetzt hier kannst du auch
die position und die drehung und
skalierung anwählen wir brauchen beide
nur die position ja dann kannst du noch
über ziel bearbeiten eine ebene
auswählen auf denen wir uns einen
gepflegten daten drauf gehen wenn du
dann auch vorwärts analysieren drückt
dann berechnet der klavier versucht halt
alles zu tracken sieht man jetzt hier
bin ich das mal gerade mache
dass er sofort den punkt verloren hat
einfach weil er der kontrast nicht so
gut ist aber dadurch dass es nicht so
lang war der ganze clip kann man einfach
frame für frame siehst du das einfach
ende stand immer nach
beispiel auf der nur leben hab ich dann
die ganzen sieht man jede ganzen
keyframes die einzige was diese heute
sucht das rote genau das ist jetzt
konsulat
in dem wir das alles geprägt haben das
hat die bewegung die genommen
zauberschlag gemacht hat geht ein ja und
dann
wenn du das alles betrifft hast dann
hast du doch eine neue ebene und sowieso
eine extra einstellungsebene wurde quasi
nur die werte von der position die
ganzen keyframes gespeichert sind und
dann kannst du quasi effekte alles was
du möchtest kannst du dann quasi damit
verbinden also sucht sie jetzt einfach
so ein lichteffekt daraus leite raves
genau man kate prinzip sind aber auch
die einstellungsebene
und dann bekommst du jetzt hier so eine
art heller machen ja noch kann man mit
den werten spielen kannst den radius
verändern die intensität wie stark
sollten leuchten du kannst hier das
ganze ding noch ein werden was man in
unserem fall auch machen muss man
natürlich ein bisschen ist ein blauer
hatten und natürlich kann er nicht von
anfang an irgendwie eine durchgängige
einen durchgängigen radios haben oder
eine durchgängige auch der muss ja
erstmal so erscheinen genau der muss
erst mal quasi ganz leicht anfangen und
dann halt immer stärker werden und wie
lange sitzt du dann an so einem effekt
eigentlich geht es relativ schnell weil
wie gesagt wie sehr er nicht lang die
tracks ist einmal das geht relativ zehn
minuten dann suchst du den effekt aus
praxen auf die ebene drauf und da musste
ich auch wieder einfach nur viel
händisch mit keyframes arbeiten das
jetzt möglich du siehst dass du quasi
einfach hier haben wir die breiten ist
also die helligkeit von dem effekt auf
100 prozent dann geht es einfach an den
anfang war silos anfängst zusagen machen
es darauf 0 haben wir wieder zwei
keyframes ihn gepackt und dann wird
einfach die helligkeit
langsam und gleichmäßig hochskaliert und
dann ist quasi auch gleichzeitig mit dem
wir die lampe hinten angeht ich meine
ich ganz gut wirkt es so als würde durch
den zauberstab
der ganze raum beleuchtet werden und wie
gesagt dann halt die lichtquelle noch
blau einfärben damit es schön zu dem
sich dem hintergrund hast du hast
natürlich die einstellungsebene und die
kannst du dann mit diesem tool
mit dem neuen objekt verbindet damit die
position nicht händisch machen muss okay
das wäre ja noch meine frage gewesen
zusätzlich muss das in diesem fall ist
so anders ist über die
location ist quasi wo befindet sich der
lichtpunkt und dann kannst du über
wald und dann noch die stoppuhr symbol
drückst du kannst du denn dann
verbinden hast du dieses tool und dann
einfach auch die eu braucht kommen wir
mal wieder zurück zum video wie lange
hast jetzt an dem video geschnitten
einen tag also ich schneide sonst an
normalen videos schneide ich auch einen
tag auf seinem kopfball an der schneide
ich manchmal zu drei tage kommt ja auch
noch mal darauf an wie lange das video
am ende sein soll und was beim schnitt
natürlich nochmal ausmacht wenn man
vorher ein skript hat kann man sich beim
schnitt natürlich an diesem skript
halten und dann dauert es nicht so lange
wenn man dreht wir zum beispiel im
youtube stil dass ich so ein komplettes
ball und macht dann passiert da nichts
im roten faden dann muss man einfach
gucken dass man im schnitt an den roten
faden selber bastelt wir schauen mal was
soundeffekte jetzt aus machen
[Musik]
und da habe ich ein bisschen versucht
darauf zu achten dass die musik dass wir
jetzt hier kurz bevor der humus sagst
dass man so ein partnern wo es quasi
kurz leider wird - und dann die musik
auch wieder so
steigt das ist ein bisschen ja ja ja die
damit halt bekommen dass man meinem eine
gesprochene zeile noch dazu
[Musik]
klingt gut mir zeigt mal mitgenommen
erzählt er noch sound effekte für die
für den spruch ansicht unterlegt macht
wenn ihr mal so viel mehr macht es ganze
ding runter braucht ihr noch mehr leben
allein
[Musik]
klar man muss manchmal hätte ich gar
nicht gedacht dass das jetzt so viel
ausmacht vom sound effect her und logos
maximalsatz war auch mega gut aus war
aber auch so einfach es hat jemand die
lampe an gemacht als ich du musst
maximal gesagt habe du musst maximal
der akku zauberspruch war auch ganz
ausgeklügelt ausgedacht also an die hat
halt ein buch geworden als ich gesagt
habe und dann ist es meine hand geflogen
ich finde aber es sieht mega cool aus
jeder schritt den wir uns sparen
[Musik]
noch mal an schwung
[Gelächter]
mit einem land
mit den arm wer
das
locog dem buch
6 was ihrem geheimnis gibt es auch sehen
könnt ist das ist ganz schön viele
anläufe manchmal gibt für einen satz
oder dass ich nicht oft verspreche oder
irgendwie den satz so ausspreche dass es
mir nicht gefällt in dem video wirkt sie
einmal so als auch die person einfach
flüssig die ganze zeit daher redet aber
das ist ganz oft nicht der fall in
dieser in diesem rezept brauchen wir
butter in diesem rezept brauchen wir wir
beginnen mit der butter stop stil wir
gehen dann mit dem router switches war
mega cool dass wir dieses mal zu dritt
waren ich merke dass wenn man mit
mehreren leuten an etwas arbeitet da so
ein paar ideen noch hin und her geworfen
werden und da habe ich entsteht
irgendwie was viel hochwertigeres als
wenn alles immer nur aus einem kopf
kommt teamwork make streamwork und so
ist timo dann auch auf die idee gekommen
mit dieser zeitung die man aus harry
potter kennt wo dumbledore mal drauf war
also diesen effekt gab es ab und zu mal
bei harry potter und den haben wir auch
genommen da muss ich aber timo sagen wie
es funktioniert also für diesen tag als
propheten effekt zeitungs effekt habe
ich mir erst mal ein template gesucht
für diese zeitung dass ich nicht dass
alles irgendwie selber eintragen musste
das quasi wie eine voreingestellte
diesem preset quasi was jemand gebaut
hat wo die einzelnen bausteine aber
verändern kann das war einfach super
viel arbeit abnimmt für die einfachen
basic schritte wo findet man so ein
template da gibt es verschiedene
plattformen für die mehrzahl mosers weg
war sie
stock footage mäßig okay was man ja sehr
gutes beispiel haben wir nur das layout
vom tablet das dann eben so gebaut dass
du die einzelnen baukasten steine hier
verändern kann aber das natürlich alles
erstmal anzulegen für seine arbeit da so
stimmt der dich dann alles selber jetzt
gebaut jetzt natürlich viel länger
gedauert hätte ich das niemals geschafft
oder erstmal die ganzen texte layouten
muss die schriften naja und formatieren
dann ist bewegt sich das ja noch so mit
diesen genommen und jetzt kannst du
quasi einfach hier in verschiedenen
bauteilen also zum beispiel deine
verschiedenen unter kompositionen wo er
neben alle texte drin sind und die doo
verändern kannst und so dürfen zb ja mal
rein dann kannst du dir aussuchen was
soll die headline sein bei uns natürlich
cocktail feuerwehr ist damit mal jeweils
den cocktail den wir dann in der runde
vorstellen eben eingebaut ansonsten kann
es eben auch hier die kleineren sachen
hier zum beispiel kannst alles rein
tragen da kannst du dich hier direkt
runter zutaten für einen feurigen
touring flamme handspiel okay also geht
es dann eigentlich relativ schnell
angenommen wie es verändert die sachen
werden uns weiter element kannst aber
auch 3d darstellen lassen after effects
und dann kannst du das drehen hin und
her bewegen wie du möchtest und das
steuer so lang war sie einfach über die
kamera nutzen möchte mich immer sie ist
wird kamera öffnest dass wir immer deine
position und deine drehung in die
x-achse y aktion z achse und jetzt
möchte ich etwas verändert sie liegt
auch hier schon quasi letzte das ganze
3d moderne bist du genau wissen raum ist
raus siehst du das liest sich zuerst
bewegt verändert können aber es war okay
frames und baust dann quasi so die
kamerafahrt wie sie ihm fahren soll ich
werde am anfang einmal raus dann sieht
man die texte ein
okay er ist genau und geht dann kolbe
durch papier und unsere nächste
komposition ja wo wir dann eigentlich
gleich noch mal am boden wie die
textänderung namen wird er von raus nach
rein damit wir wieder von der zeitung
über gehen und unser richtiges material
und wieder video dann im endeffekt
landen dass wir quasi unseren eingang
mit video haben und aus gegangen
ja das habe ich sogar verstanden mit up
perfekt zur arbeit wenn man ein bisschen
geübt ist das ist ja dann eigentlich
relativ simpel wenn man geübt ist wenn
man ein bisschen ungeübter ist dann
reizt vielleicht auch manchmal schon mit
green screen zu arbeiten was ich ganz
gerne mache und einfach mit green screen
einen effekt zu erzielen bietet mir die
zutaten und dann kommt da so ein glitzer
und das würde ich gerne mit green screen
machen wir uns jetzt hier diesen
wunderbaren vorschau clips runtergeladen
von der doppelstock den haben uns rein
gezogen jetzt natürlich noch das adobe
stock logo drin aber wir wollen erstmal
gucken auf dem auch passen hier ist
unser unsere klitschko ihn anwenden
wollen wenn man besser auf die flaschen
tipp das einmal so kleinjung sparkle
effekt gibt genau das legen wir uns erst
mal drüber gehen auf den effekt leiter
und da geben wir ultra die hand ist
quasi das kleine tool von premiere die
unsere reiter dann können wir die ki
fahrer auswählen drücken auf die
komplette
und dann sieht man nur noch das was
quasi auf dem green screen drauf ist und
nicht mehr das grün genommen und hat
jetzt auch genug
naja so jetzt machen wir mal auf der
schlagsahne ziehen wir das hier rüber
und mein pulsschlag war und so einfach
könnt ihr dann einen green screen effekt
ein baum
und dann natürlich niemand soundeffekte
unterlegen sorry
zauberhafte schlange und
schlagsahne und 24 und jetzt müssen die
metro
rückschlag schlange und mal als sie ihr
merkt es ist gar nicht mal so schwer so
ein tolles video zu erstellen das
wichtigste bei einem großen projekt ist
teamwork team extreme uhr hat dir der
schnitt spaß gemacht tatsächlich ja ja
also die effekte nun muss an so ist dann
immer schön zu sehen das ist dann doch
so mit einfachen mitteln eigentlichen
coolen effekt erzielen kann indem man
einfach so eine kleine stablampe nimmt
sich auf dem boden kullert aber mal an
macht und da darf jetzt wunderbar cool
aus wir haben echt endeffekt sehr
gefeiert also das war wirklich sehr sehr
cool zum teil
arbeitet gerne mit adobe
ausschließlich hier möglich die gruppe
möglichkeiten und das geil ist dass die
programme so ein mega ist
ineinandergreifen das soll ich aussagen
alle programme sind so du aber ein
lightroom premiere einfach clip
anklicken kannst du den acht effekt
packen kannst und ihren verbunden und
wenn du warst ein effekt ändert wird es
direkt im premiere geändert das ist
einfach ein sehr gute des ineinander
gleiten das system wenn nicht ja und
jetzt zurück ins studio und so einfach
macht ihr eigenes video mit special
effects es dauert zwar ein paar tage bis
es dann fertig ist aber dafür ist das
ergebnis mega cool oder falls es noch
nicht gesehen habe dann schaut euch das
video unbedingt an ich bin sehr stolz
drauf ich finde wir haben sehr gute
arbeit geleistet und die rezepte sind
sehr gut wir sehen uns das nächste mal
wieder ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
die adobe creative cloud könnt ihr unten
einmal link anklicken und euch da alles
anschauen es gibt immer ganz gute
rabatte für studierende und azubis und
lehrkräfte und wir waren ja gerade in
der black friday mit bzw sind wir
vielleicht noch in der black friday wie
schaut mal an ich schreibe es dann unten
rein und weil es in diesem berufsfeld
arbeitet was euch vielen job gemacht
könnte es mir gerne wagen wieder
und jetzt ist man richtig kein schnitt
effekt
war wo ist sie bei